[Music]
with our satellites today we can pick up
radiation actually from the Big Bang
itself a few hundred thousand years
after the Big Bang radiation was
released about the universe that is now
in the microwave range believe it or not
when he turned on the TV and you pick up
static when you turn on the radio and
you pick up static some of that static
comes from creation itself you can
actually listen to some degree to the
actual explosion that created the
universe however this explosion dates
from a few hundred thousand years after
the instant of creation we're not
satisfied we physicists want to go to
the instant of the Big Bang itself and
that's what the Hadron Collider will do
it'll recreate conditions not seen since
perhaps a trillionth of a second after
creation itself and we hope the Large
Hadron Collider will unlock some of the
deepest secrets of space and time matter
and energy
[Music]